brothers and sisters respected guests
thank you for joining us on our latest
installment of zed
authored by the late and esteemed
scholar of islam
shem siddin ibn
a scholar a distinguished scholar of the
7th and 8th century of islam
we left off in our previous episode
speaking about
what the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam
would usually recite or at least the
length of his recitation
during salat elisha
it's been narrated that he recited surah
13 which is
fairly it's about a half a page
he says
[Silence]
roughly the length of surat shems
surat al-ali surat
and that length which does not exceed
more than a page
while he had the ankara
muay the bin jebel for leading his
people in salat alasha
as an imam and reciting surat al-baqarah
the longest chapter in the quran
and he asked muad
are you someone who hinders people from
the path of allah
he says
he says but this narration has been
taken out of context
now this is
that this narration of the narration is
collected
in he mentions that this has been taken
out of context by people who
tend to laziness or tend to
just to stir up trouble and controversy
he says people usually look at this
narration and take it
out of its context
not looking to what the story
was the environment and the context in
which this
chapter then was in which this hadith
actually was said by the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
what is that context let us discuss that
context now
so that we understand why
as we mentioned in our previous episode
is one of the
most knowledgeable scholars of islam
one of the most knowledgeable scholars
from amongst the companions
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he has many merits
and in muslim ahmed the prophet
said
he said the most knowledgeable of this
nation with regards to the laws of
prohibit
prohibition and lawfulness meaning in
the religion of allah
is
was a very young man in the time of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
despite his youth he was dispatched by
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
to entire lands of not muslims to
call the people of those lands to islam
and to act as a judge and governor of
those lands
and so was sent to yemen
he was sent to yemen in the narration of
ibn abbas and also
collected by a muslim the famous
narration
in which the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
you arrive in yemen you will come upon a
people
of the people of the book and
the first thing that you are to invite
them to
and to call them to is to testify
that none is rightfully worshipped but
allah
and then muhammad is the messenger of
he said and if they agree to this and
they submit themselves in this sense
then you are to inform them
about the five obligatory prayers that
allah has
made binding upon his servants
etcetera etcetera a well-known narration
well adam and jebel died
at around the age of 34 early 30s
and he died in the plague of amwas which
took place in hashem
during the time of
a few years after the prophet salallahu
salem's death
and so during the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam's time
in jebel was in his 20s and
despite this youth he was already being
dispatched and sent to lands
as a scholar and representative of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
now that's a little bit of a back story
about moab
now we understand his stature
and his standing amongst the rest of the
companions of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
now we discuss this story here that
evening is speaking about
there's a narration in which this
narration many people
memorize the wording of this narration
but very few people know the backdrop
and context of this narration
the narration goes as follows the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam rebuked
and he said to him
he asked him rhetorically moab are you
somebody who hinders away from the path
of allah do you wish to turn people away
from allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
what is the context of this narration
so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would pray in his mosque
would join prayer behind the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
alaihi wasallam after salat
was concluded
in the prophet muhammad sallam's mosque
and jebel would then go to his village
in in medina in the outskirts of medina
and
he would find his people there in their
local masjid
waiting for him and he would come and
then he would lead them in salah
why did he do this well he did this
because
he wanted to have the virtue of leading
his people in salah
but he also wanted to have the virtue of
praying
behind the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and
in the masjid of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
due to the multiple rewards that a
person will get
and so we take a number of
evidences from this narration but one of
them is that the imam
can have a different intention in his
prayer
than the one who is praying behind him
right
how is that praying obligatory prayer of
reisha with the prophet muhammad
then he is going to his masjid
and he's leading the people in in salah
but he's already prayed asia
and so he has already prayed isha
and so he is counting this prayer as a
sunnah as a nafilah
as something which is not binding but
the people behind him
are counting this prayer as the
obligatory
salah so we see that the imam
and the person praying behind the imam
they have different intentions
but that's okay as long as the imam
has the intention to lead others in
prayer
and so
he went a little bit overboard with his
zeal
and his love for the quran in the sense
that
he would go back to his village
people are already waiting it's already
night time
people are tired they're waiting to go
home to sleep
and they also have fajita which is
coming very soon
and so muad would arrive there at that
masjid
only to then oftentimes
lead his people in an extremely lengthy
prayer
some of the time he was narrated to have
recited the entirety of surah till
baqarah
the longest chapter in the quran well
there was a young man praying behind
and this young man had work
and he actually when he saw that the
recitation was continuing and continuing
and that was reciting and reciting and
reciting
this man broke out of salah
went to a vacant corner of the masjid
prayed salah on his own and then he left
who finished his prayer others that were
present said to muath
you know there was this young man he did
x y and z
that this individual is clearly a
hypocrite
and that was
based on the way that he is seeing it
that who would not want to sit there and
listen to the quran
there there was no way to listen to the
quran at that time unless you're in
prayer
there was no recordings
there was no recording of the quran that
you could put into a
tape recorder or you know listen to on
the internet or stream it or something
there's no radios the only way that you
can listen to the quran
is if a you know how to read which was a
very very
rare skill to have literacy was
extremely rare in the time
of the prophet or
b you went to to listen to it recited by
a scholar
and usually that would be insulted
and so why would you forfeit the
opportunity and the very rare
opportunity to hear
the words of allah
and so based on these circumstances
who made this comment later
this was brought to the attention of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
who was also approached by this young
man
this young man heard what had been said
about him and he approached
the prophet alaihi wasallam complaining
about what had occurred and so he said
we're tired comes and he leads us
in prayer of irisha with suratul bakr
and i'm very tired and i have work et
cetera et cetera
and the prophet salallahu asked him
what do you say in your prayer when you
pray
he said i am a simple man
i'm not very good with words you
and moaeth i ask allah for paradise
and i seek forgiveness from allah and
protection
from the hellfire
he said
he said and i am not good with words
you and wife
to you know with all these to to
expound upon those meanings any more
than that
i'm a simple man i i basically my prayer
revolves around asking allah for
paradise and seeking refuge from the
hell fire
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said
he said this is the main
concept that all of our
talk revolves around in our prayer
that's the essence of
prayer essentially and so then
he said to moab this very famous
statement
this is the concept this is the context
in which this statement was made
muhammad is already
arriving late for isha not late because
he's
not on time late meaning that was the
time
of isha to be made that they had agreed
upon
it was a later time because again he had
to pray with the prophet
so moab would muhammad there find the
people waiting for him
and then after all of that he's going to
lead them in prayer for
two or three hours for salah
so in this context under these
circumstances
the prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
rebuked and he said
essentially saying this behavior
this action of making salah too long
will cause salah to be in the people
of
in the minds of some people will make
salah out to be a kind of nuisance
a kind of heavy daunting task and people
will not want to pray anymore
so you will essentially by doing this
with good intentions obviously we do not
in any way bring
the intentions of
or look at his intentions with any
suspect
rather with good intentions you are
inadvertently causing prayer which
should be something that relieves
and brings a sense of relief and solace
to the people
you are now turning it into because of
your lengthy prayer
into something which is a daunting
task right and so what will happen
yeah i mean this could continue for a
while
and there will be some people who will
continue to pray behind
with a heavy heart and people will start
to stop going to the masjid et cetera et
cetera
right and so
this statement now taken out of context
has become something that is memorized
and
and regurgitated by people
so if the mamm recites for two minutes
right now we we find it
appropriate to bring up this
narration
this statement the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's rebuke of
was under these circumstances
if the imam stands and leads people in
salat al-ashaf for an hour or two hours
yes this is the proper place
and the proper context in which to bring
the rebuke of the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam
as a rebuke for this kind of imam
not because the imam recited
a few seconds longer than you are
accustomed to
right the longest recitation
an imam is going to usually have in
these times for
especially in you know a place here
where people are working and they have
schedules to abide by etcetera
is not going to exceed 10 or 15 minutes
this is not the right context to say
afternoon
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
never rebuked
for 10 or 15 minutes the rebuke was for
two or three or four hours
right and so we are to understand the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
words
in the proper context so after this
after he rebuked moab he then taught
moab and said
if you when you lead people in prayer
lead them with chapters such as
surah the shems surah
etc that length right
that length he says
now we've discussed what the prophet
salallahu asallam was narrated to have
recited
in all of the five daily prayers and the
length
of these prayers now let's discuss
what he would recite and lead people in
prayer
on the day of jumu' friday prayer
and also the aid prayers
if no question goes on to say well
is
[Silence]
which is roughly approximately two pages
each
he says and sometimes and oftentimes
which
[Silence]
to merely recite portions or the
tail ends of these chapters then this
is something that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam has never done
it's never it's never something that he
had done
right what does that mean well
because people are so hasty because
people are in such a
haste and in such a rush to finish
prayer and get out of the masjid
some imams wanted to
recite the chapters that the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would recite
during jumu' salah but if they recite
the entire thing it would be too
too much for them for the people
listening so
sometimes many iman started to recite
just the
end of these two chapters
and even the end of
surah till allah and surah till russia
so often times you'll go to salah
the imam in s
and finish the chapter from there
and then when it comes to surat
al-munahfir they will
oftentimes begin
starting at the end of these two
chapters
so you can't recite the entire chapter
you just recite a few verses from its
end
ibn al-qayyam says this is not something
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam ever did
and we have a principle to take
and that principle tells us from the
sunnah that
the nature of recitation of the quran
should would usually be in the time of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam if he started a chapter he
would end the chapter
right so if he started in surat al-araf
he would end the entire chapter
in the first record or in both
two rakah in the entire prayer in its
entirety collectively
either this or this but it is extremely
rare
that the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam
ever recited a few verses from any
particular chapter
when he would recite a chapter and not
finish the entire chapter he would
always start from the beginning
this is something that's actually very
very important
does this mean that we cannot recite
any verses of the quran from anywhere
the answer is no you can recite
any portion of the quran because allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala gave us
a command he said
recite whatever is easy for you to
recite right
so you can recite any portion of the
quran any verse
taken from any chapter that is fine
but just because you can do it doesn't
mean
that it is necessarily the sunnah of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
doesn't necessarily mean that that's
what he used to do
and we mentioned this before we
mentioned the difference between
with the scholars of usual with the
scholars of
hermeneutics that
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would do something
and he would allow something there's a
difference between the two
there's a difference between something
which is ja is
permissible acceptable and something
which is the sunnah
meaning that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam used to do this
there's a difference not everything that
is acceptable
is necessarily the sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
he would recite in the first raqqa
suratul
in the second surah
but to just snip out a couple of verses
from each chapter
and make that the norm that you always
every juma
will recite that that is not the
son of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
this is the point that ibn al-qaeda
is making
now how was his recitation well
he would always start from the beginning
and if he is and usually finish the
chapter
no matter what chapter it is in prayer
however if he did not he would usually
start at the beginning
very very rarely do we have anywhere
where it's narrated that the prophet
salallahu would begin with any
portion of verses
that are not the beginning of a
particular chapter
this is something very rare and if no
qualium will get into this later
and there's a very good reason for this
and that is that
the beginning of the chapter is
oftentimes
a it is the place where the theme of the
entire
chapter is going to be derived from
the theme and the climate of the rest of
the chapter
is found in the beginning verses the
opening verses of any
given chapter of the quran it's going to
give you a few key
principles and then is going to expound
upon those principles throughout the
chapter
and then we'll usually conclude with
referring back to the beginning in some
way this is how the quran usually works
right and so if i just snatch
certain things it becomes very easy to
take things out of context and context
is
part of the text people
oftentimes do not understand that
context is part of the meaning of the
actual
statement that context is absolutely
necessary to understand
he says and as for in the eid
prayers sometimes he would recite surat
and surah which is
he would recite them completely so he
would recite surat of
about two and a half
about two and a half pages
which is about two and a half pages as
well and sometimes he would recite surat
and suratul each in
each recast so the first raqqa of
salat
he would recite surat sabbah and in the
second record he would recite surat
he says
this is what the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam customarily did
all the way until he passed away and met
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and for this reason the
successors of the prophet muhammad
would recite this length
and these particular chapters when they
led salah
after his death
he says
he said and abu bakr had led
the companions when he was the
successor of the prophet salallahu he
had led the companions
in surat al-baqarah in salat al-fajr
in fajr he recited surah till baqarah
and this recitation was so long that
when he
made tesleem concluding the prayer
he the sun was almost
going to rise meaning it took several
hours
he says and likewise after abu bakr's
time
in the era of and his successorship
he would lead the companions and lead
the people
in salah
and he would recite surat yosuf
chapters that are roughly that long
right
if we took that in today's terms in the
way that the companions used to recite
the quran
we're talking about a prayer that would
last anywhere from
45 minutes to an hour and fifteen
minutes roughly for salat elisha
right now you may say well wait i can
read the quran faster than that yes
but to read the quran properly
aloud this takes a lot of time
something surah yusuf surah nahil
suratud suratul israel this will take at
least
about an hour why because it's not just
the recitation
but it is also the rest of the prayer
that is involved
and as ibn al-qaeda will get into it
we'll mention later
that the prayer is supposed to be
similar meaning a person when he stands
to recite
his should complement that recitation it
should be similar in length
when a person makes sujud their sujud
should be
similar in length to the roku and the
recitation
not that a person recites 20 minutes and
then rukur is
20 seconds and then sujud is
30 minutes again this is not correct
this is a lopsided prayer it is all
supposed to be
proportionate to one another right
he says
he says and as for the statement of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam when he says if any of you
leads the people in prayer then he is to
make that prayer brief he says
he says what is meant by brevity here in
this narration
brevity here is relative relative to
what
relative to what the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam used to do
right so if i say brief and you say
brief we may have very different
meanings
right brief for me might be an hour and
brief for you might be
10 minutes which one of us is correct
if no clayim says the yardstick of
brevity here
what is meant by it is it is relative
brevity
meaning that the prayer is brief
with regards to how brief the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
alaihi wasallam would make his prayer so
the sunnah
is the yardstick of brevity here
what is not the measuring stick the
yardstick
of brevity would be
whatever people desire you know people
want it to be 30 seconds so that's now
the sunnah that's not how it works
he says and the customs of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
wasallam those things which he did
continuously
until he left this earth this is the
judging factor in anything
that is different upon amongst the
people amongst contenders in
debates what is the yardstick
of correct and incorrect what is the
yardstick of appropriate and
inappropriate
we look at the sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and we see what it is that he used to do
and what was his constant pattern
in that particular thing that is the
yardstick that is the measuring stick
now there are other narrations and again
this is something which goes back to
alma facet
it goes back to greater good and greater
evil
right it's very good to be in prayer
however the evil that may happen
is causing people to not listen to the
quran anymore
and maybe even cringe at hearing the
quran because
the quran will then signify to them a
daunting task
this is not correct what does that mean
well let's say the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam would recite in salat
yusuf okay
and let's say you live in chicago or you
live in a metropolitan
area and you have to be to work at a
particular time
right and
especially in major urban cities we see
that traffic starts at a very specific
time
and that traffic or the distance of your
work or whatever it is
all of these factor into you being late
or on time
affecting your livelihood
is it better for the imam who is the
imam
that's usually his job is to lead people
in prayer
right as far as he is concerned he's on
time he's doing what his job is
there's people behind him that are
praying that are
under time constraints that is for
jummah that is for fajr that's for any
prayer
is it better for me at this point to as
an imam
to lead someone who is
under these set of circumstances to lead
them in fajr with surat yusuf
yes they heard the quran but on the flip
side
they'll probably stop coming to the
masjid for fajr anymore
altogether because it's now affecting
their livelihood
perhaps now while you're reciting
in that same prayer the recitation went
from
listening to the quran with an open
heart to all i can think about is i need
to go to work now
and i wish this man would stop reciting
and finish
this is not the point of prayer right
and this is not correct and for this
reason
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
assad
to one of the companions one of the
companions said make me the imam of my
people my village in prayer
he said
[Silence]
you are the imam of your people in your
village i
appoint you as such take for yourself
and appoint
a vin someone to call it then who will
not take
pay for his ad then
right for his services and
him follow and make your recitation
and make your prayer according to the
weakest
amongst your followers right
there's people who are sick there's
people who have things that they need to
do
there are people who are under time
constraints there's people that are
tired
there's women that have to tend to their
children there's men that have to
tend to their children whatever it is
right
and so you don't want to make a
dichotomy right between
the religion religious duties and
worldly duties you don't want to have
those two clashing
if at all possible sometimes they clash
and there's no way around that
and in those rare circumstances we go
with
preserving our religion and our
religious duties
and that takes precedence over our
worldly duties
but that's not the case all of the time
we don't want to set up any
clash that doesn't have to be there if
you can
do a portion of each that is better than
choosing one or the other
right and so
he says use as your guide
the weakest amongst your followers
meaning if i'm going to pray
let's say the weakest amongst them
whether it's because of illness
or because of something that he has to
do
or somewhere he has to be whatever it is
let's say that
that person can only handle a
five-minute prayer or ten minute prayer
but there are those who are praying
behind me that can handle an
hour prayer no in this case i need to
make the prayer five minutes
or ten minutes whatever it is
why because this way everyone
gets what they came for from the salah
and again it's not just about length
it's about quality the quality of prayer
right intensity is much more important
than
extensity as the scholars
tell us
he says as another general rule
as a general rule there is no
prayer in which the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam specified
a particular
surah that would be recited every single
time this way during this prayer
except for the prayer of jumu' and the
prayer of eid
this is what ibn is tells us
now there are other prayers which he
would most commonly
recite certain things salat al-fajr
on the day of jumu'
he would commonly recite in the first
raka surah
sajdah in the second surat in sen right
and the two deka of
the sunnah of fajr in the first
he would often recite suratul kafirun
and the second he would often recite
surat
al-ikhlas right etc etc
these are common things that he would do
but it's not something that he would
never diverge from
contrary to salat he would
always recite in jumuah and read the
chapters that we mentioned
previously it would be
[Silence]
these are the only prayers
in which he was narrated to have recited
these particular chapters every time
during these prayers any other prayer
this is just something that was commonly
narrated
but not necessarily the absolute
norm that he would not diverge from
next episode insha allah we will
start to discuss
how the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would recite
in each prayer what kind of recitation
it would be we'll get into more details
with regards to that
foreign